vous Myriam quand vous avez fait sweet
dimanche soir pour vous étiez énervé du
résultat ah mais j'étais pas énervée
j'étais dégoûté franchement j'étais
presque en
dépressions
en tant que journaliste et et je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi moi en tant que
journaliste je refuse de donner ma voix
à Emmanuel Macron j'invite tout le monde
à regarder les programmes je ne dis pas
qui il faut voter chacun est libre de
faire ce qu'il veut donc voilà mais moi
en tant que en tant que journaliste je
refuse de voter manuel Macron sur la fin
j'ai pas et bonne oui mais je vais vous
dire pourquoi les journalistes doivent
aussi se prononcer parce que ça fait
partie de leur métier d'avoir des
opinions pourquoi pourquoi vous avez
fait ce truc alors dites-nous pourquoi
j'ai fait ce tweet tout simplement parce
que je suis une maman et qu'en tant que
maman je refuse à venir que vous
proposer aux enfants JO à mes enfants je
refuse un avenir avec un QR code pour
faire les activités du quotidien un
avenir avec impasse sanitaire pour avoir
accès aux soins un avenir ou on va les
obliger à se faire vacciner avec un
vaccin qui est subi une enquête
aujourd'hui aux États pour les faire des
Irak je refuse que mes enfants quand ils
vont manifester pour crier liberté on
leur envoie les blindés sur les
Champs-Élysées je refuse que mes enfants
c'est ce qui s'est passé monsieur je
refuse que mes enfants quand ils vont
lutter pour leur pouvoir d'achat dans
comme les gilets jaunes on les aborde et
ils soient victimes de violences
policières comme ça n'a jamais été
autant le cas sous un sous un quinna je
refuse que mes enfants comme 8 millions
de Français ils aillent à la banque
alimentaire je refuse que mes enfants
oui je refuse de mes enfants ou alors
aînés crever dans les EHPAD et avec du
rivotrip je refuse que mes enfants
soient masqués du matin au soir alors
que notre président fait la avec le
président portugais sans masque et sans
geste barrière voilà pourquoi je refuse
de voter Macron et pourquoi je
n'encouragerai pas les gens à côté et je
vous dis ça en ayant voté moi-même
Macron il y a 5 ans j'ai fondé
énormément d'espoir sur sa candidature
mais croire aujourd'hui que Manuel
Macron est un homme démocrate et un
homme de coach c'est ce fourvoyer
totalement ce que je peux
réagir quand même
et là
d'abord
c'est votre droit c'est bien
démocratique le second tour c'est dans
10 jours et on a le droit de ne pas être
en accord l'un avec l'autre et chacun
d'être derrière un candidat ce que vous
dites est-ce que visiblement vous
refusez beaucoup Emmanuel Macron c'est
la politique qui a été menée pendant la
crise sanitaire le
QR code que vous mentionnez a sauvé des
milliers et des milliers de voix de vie
pardon on peut ne pas être d'accord avec
ça mais moi je considère que la manière
et quelques voix sans doute au passage
en effet
et qui ne pensent pas la vie de nos
enfants dans ce résultat qui visiblement
vous a dépli dimanche que la crise
sanitaire n'avait pas été trop mal géré
en France mais surtout on parle des
programmes
moi je suis fier aujourd'hui que le
chômage des jeunes en France il soit au
plus bas depuis 40 ans je suis fier
aujourd'hui qui est plus d'apprenti en
France qu'en Allemagne alors cependant
des décennies on regardait les Allemands
avec envie et nous nos jeunes ils
étaient au chômage moi je suis fier
aujourd'hui qu'on est un programme qui
va mettre le paquet sur l'éducation des
jeunes pour leur donner un job oui moi
je suis à partir de 12 ans oui bien sûr
qu'aujourd'hui
aux françaises aux Français leur sujet
de préoccupation le chômage est
maintenant en 14e position il y a 5 ans
il était dans le top 3 on a aujourd'hui
vaincu un fléau en tout cas en étant
passe de vaincre un fléau historique qui
est le chômage et notamment de chômage
des jeunes ça veut pas dire qu'on a tout
bien fait sans doute parmi vos critiques
il y en a qui sont recevables et c'est
bien pour ça que je pense qu'il faut
continuer avec Emmanuel Macron pour
continuer à investir mais je suis
convaincu que pour vos enfants Emmanuel
Macron bien meilleur choix que Marine Le
penchéte ne doit pas voter pour Emmanuel
Macron